hidey-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John
we're gonna watch today the trailer for
Dumbo it's just the Disney week isn't
that exciting Disney day before we go
into this I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's been following with us on
the Stardust app yo over there we do
30-second reactions for films TV shows
and trailers a lot of them are micro
sketches mini reviews it's a blasty
blast it's free to download it's free to
use so I hope you're Dumbo ass follows
us first hear that children you
shouldn't be watching internet this late
at night let's get to it it's like a
swearing hack right there
by the way watch our Ralph breaks the
internet review ok that's neat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Colin Farrell
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude it's Batman and penguin talking
yeah
[Music]
Gintama Becky sack Jesus mom do
something she is all is lost
[Music]
a green a local at a bottom starters
replacement yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
looks so adorable I wasn't even really
paying attention to the plot certain
that damn elephant sure I was like look
how freaking cute that thing is man oh
yeah that was that was one thing that I
was thinking having rewatched the
trailer for the animated movie is like
the teaser gave me kind of a melancholy
vibe and this gave me a much more acute
yeah other than the tone it's not super
different that from what we got from the
last trailer I don't really remember the
Dumbo that I made a movie all that well
it looks like they've rearranged the
story beats for sure and it looks like I
mean the mouse character doesn't look
like it's in here at all yeah replaced
by the children ostensibly at least see
in terms of like the feather and then go
back with that stuff it looks like
anyway Oh either way man I I'm really
looking forward to this this kind of
feels like Tim Burton that's so going
back to like his roots of you know
Beetlejuice or whatever even though you
do have Michael Keaton and Danny DeVito
here which I immediately don't like it's
bad what I think about is big fish this
really gets the big fish vibe and I love
that movie I find that to be one of Tim
Burton's most underrated flicks and you
know I've maybe because there's this
whole section in that movie dedicated to
the circus that's where I'm getting a
lot of that aesthetic and flair from I
heard something about Tim Burton and
Disney having some type of weird falling
out but you know Dumbo oh my good it
doesn't make any logical sense to me why
that would be occurring I don't know I
mean the thing about me is I really like
this trailer I like what we're getting
out of it and I'm still at that point
with Tim Burton where I don't know if
this is just a good trailer because Tim
Burton's movies can still cut good
trailers and it's been a while since
I've really felt the passion behind the
camera from him especially in movies of
this caliber it's this much weight on
their shoulders to recapture some of
that classic magic and stuff like that
and I feel like the circus and and these
kinds of aesthetics are well within Tim
burns wheelhouse the thing I want to
believe is that he can actually make a
beautiful double movie and not just show
up and point the camera because on a lot
of these that's kind of how I felt with
him lately especially like I don't I
don't get that impression here at all
you know I don't know if Tim Burton has
some type of magical passionate Flair
for Dumbo like if this is like a
childhood favorite of his or whatever
for some reason just looking at this
there seems to be a
real heart there seems to be a real tail
that he wants to tell here I'm looking
forward to the performances man's like
for some reason I rarely feel like I see
Colin Farrell get to shine in a
protagonist role these days and if it is
a protagonist it's kind of like a dark
haunted character and from what I get is
someone from the war lost his arm and
now he's doing this but he looks like
you know a really solid good guy here
Michael Keaton reprising his role from
the founder join me in the big show
Danny DeVito reprising his role from big
fish I wouldn't put it past Tim Burton
to connect us today did something kind
of extreme like that yeah another one of
Albert Finney's tall tales I believe in
the cartoon Dumbo talks it doesn't look
like he's talking here this is what they
dive back on the talking animal aspect
or I don't know if I'm gonna show up to
the theater and it's I'm gonna be very
surprised if anything I kind of get sort
of those you know family vibe movies
when it's about a dog like Marley and me
were you know you got a lot of human
characters you got a lot of actors with
the core of it the center of it is this
main animal well you got a lot of good
human emotion a lot of good human
characters in here but the core is Dumbo
while there's you know imagery here in
direct references that are - the
animated movie it doesn't feel like it's
just another Disney movie where they've
adapted straight-up cartoon you know
we're looking at it I mean I don't know
what the order of events for this movie
is but it certainly looks as though
they're dropping certain plot details
earlier or it's like the whole flying
thing I imagine might come up earlier in
this movie and it looks like the
reasoning for separating him and his mom
is a little bit different because in the
cartoon like she's just upset that
everyone's being a dick to Dumbo and
like they think that she's going mad and
they put her in a crate and they're like
oh you're your crate you know you're and
this kind of just looked like oh they're
just gonna separate them I guess I
couldn't really tell but yeah it seems
like it very least there remix income of
the elements and I wonder if the songs
are gonna play in because I was one of
the big things they touted on the
original movie was seven original song
right right and you know they've been
remaking this wave of Disney classics
and some of them at least have you know
bothered with
music so I wonder if that's gonna factor
in in any way yeah I mean when you hear
Tim Burton Dumbo I feel like you might
even imagine something that's crazier
and bigger than what the trailers
currently have been showing us because
for the most part they feel a little bit
restrained and what they're what they're
communicating to us of what's gonna go
on in this like it's all just at the
circus not really hopping around a lot
of even when they're showing us the
circus stuff does another gonna shown as
a whole bunch of craziness that goes on
I'm kind of hoping though that the film
does get a little bit more fantastical
and more imaginative or for all I know
this more subdued version could be
better yeah it could I mean I'm curious
as to what their overall goal with this
is because yeah it does look a bit
different and even like looking at the
pink elephants it looks like they've
given those an actual like expletive
down to earth it's not like a drunken
dream that they have anymore
yeah yeah and so yeah I do wonder what
pitch they're gonna go with because this
trend for Disney is interesting to me
and it seems like some of them are like
verbatim just translated to live-action
and this doesn't look like it's exactly
going to do that which has me very
curious yeah and for Tim Burton - I am
curious about the scope that this exists
on because yeah it looks kind of
reminiscent of something more heartfelt
and colorful like big fish and also not
super flippin huge like Alice in
Wonderland where you're like oh my god
my eyes hurt either way man I feel like
you'll probably be a tear jerker of a
film and that dang elephant is so darn
cute and Eva green yeah you know yeah I
find someone who kind of looks like
Helena Bonham Carter
alright guys well before we wrap this up
I only gave her page from the day
shout-out to a man named James Stegen
'he's james Dagon's I want to thank you
my Dumbo friend because of the fact that
you do have big ears and you're cute and
adorable I know I kind of feel like I'm
always insulting you in these shoutouts
but I want to say you are one adorable
looking kid man also I appreciate you
always looking out for us whenever
there's a fire going on in LA you seem
to always set us up and you know I want
to make sure we're in safe hands that is
very kind of you that's Allstate's stand
and get a new job so you can increase
your pledge on patreon yeah and then you
can come out of here and fight the fires
for us instead of just asking about him
you know I never liked it you know all
right guys well thanks for watching are
you excited for Dumbo you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us out on so
much stuff bye bye